this is a production of Cornell
University
thanks everyone for joining us this is
episode two of season four the Cornell
Turf Show uh today we're going to chat
some sports turf with Ben polymer uh
he's in western Mass you guys might
remember Ben from previous episodes last
year uh we're gonna get Ben's thoughts
on on sort of starting up the spring how
how the athletes are getting out on
those fields using those fields and
we're going to get to some talk about
bmps and sports turf too we talk about
uh bmps a lot in golf course turf and
excited to talk about a new document Ben
helped put together for the for the New
England folks on Spurs 2 bmps but uh
Frank let's uh let's start off with you
as always bring my co-host Frank Rossi
in here today uh Frank let's uh let's
get going and get your thoughts on how
the season is uh might progress here
going forward okay
thanks Carl thanks me get the slides up
here
um
great to be back in our 10th year and
we're we're and in a minute you're going
to get to hear call rant which as I you
know I I really have enjoyed uh these
rants he had a great one yesterday on
the golf ball and I threw him a fish
hook in to see if he'd go for the
bifurcation argument but he didn't fall
for it he's much smarter than I am so we
have a great guest today it's going to
be a great 30 minutes and go by really
fast but I like to start out with
knucklehead stuff right Ben you know how
do you how do you plow snow and on
synthetic Fields if with someone who
doesn't know what they're doing right
this goes to the whole idea of the the
professionalism and the way sports turf
managers are perceived in their facility
operations and you know this is why we
have you Ben because it's really
important to model not just to students
and young people that want to do this
but to administrators and we're going to
get to administrators here in a minute
um but Carl before we get started I know
you've got something really interesting
that came across your desk because
you're involved uh just trying to just
being a concerned citizen how about that
a concerned citizen caring about the
grounds in the city of Ithaca tell us
about this story yeah Frank so so I
visit Cass Park down in down in Ithaca
right on the inlet very often go there
with my daughter go there with my dog
walking around uh this is a basically a
facility it's got like 12 to 13 athletic
fields there's baseball fields soccer
fields a lot of sort of intramural Youth
Sports that go on there and a lot of
walking trails as well
so they came out with a draft report of
their Capital plan they want to renovate
this area on the near future so they
came out with a draft plan uh and
requested some comments from the public
and so what I was interested in is the
turf section so as we move forward here
there's almost a 400 page document and a
lot of it is spent talking about the
natural grass fields and what they want
to do they want to amend the soils maybe
raise them up because it's right on the
water edge there's a lot of uh sort of
pond being and
action that happens they want to add
drainage maybe so that's all really good
there's a lot of meat and potatoes in
there about renovating these fields and
specs there but what I was interested in
was are they going to address the
maintenance on the back end of those
fields so as I'm reading through I see a
lot about sand specs and oh we're gonna
have to raise it this amount topography
uh it took me until page 314 out of 374
to get to the part where they talked
about maintenance considerations for the
grass athletic field so this is buried
way down in the appendix uh I guess they
get a point for addressing general
maintenance but if we read some of these
Frank the bullet point the first bullet
point they say is cut the grass shorter
during wet periods to allow more
sunlight oh go one one back there allow
more sunlight to reach the soil and
assist in drying out faster uh Frank
I've never heard that cut the cut the
grass really short scalp it down when
when the soil is saturated that's not
necessarily A best practice to me bullet
point three was another interesting one
use calcine clay and diastomaceous Earth
uh in turf grass areas maybe some of
those material use in Infield skins but
those material used in turf grass areas
May uh and you know when I'm looking at
that maybe that actually hurts the
physical properties that fairly good
recommendation there so while I
mentioned maintenance they talk about it
really generally and they actually give
some some sort of questionable
maintenance practices in there what I
was really interested in was are they
going to address the labor and Equipment
requirements the cultural practices that
are going to need to be required of
these fields they're going to be uh you
know higher end Fields than what's
currently there sort of a minimum level
are they are they projecting in the
future we're going to need more labor
and more equipment and they didn't
address that and and that's pretty
common I think in a lot of these
documents Frank you're you're not in
your head Ben is too these people put a
lot of you know these engineering forms
firms who develop these specs put a lot
into the construction and they don't
think about the maintenance what I would
say is is there's an APPA for that right
there's there's an app for that for
everything Frank uh APA the acronym is
for American physical plan Association
uh Dan shy the director of Cornell
grounds has turned me on to these
documents they talk about this is really
focused on educational facilities
buildings on how we we keep those
buildings they have a lot of tables you
know I love tables Frank I'm a table guy
a lot of tables and specs on how often
they have to maintain these areas and
they have a grounds version and they
start with expectations which is so
great they call it levels of attention
they have a one through five level uh
their level one is what they call
state-of-the-art maintenance
and that goes all the way down to level
five which is minimum maintenance and in
their grounds document they talk a lot
about the various types of grounds and
they start with levels of attention and
then the needs based on those level of
attention so you know they have examples
of baseball fields General Turf areas
landscape beds here's a here's a little
snippet of the of the soccer and
football section so they have a bunch of
the tasks mowing seating irrigation
fertilizer applications and based on
those level of attentions how much time
you're going to spend in a given week
across the season doing those things and
they total that up and they have some
really cool numbers that would be great
Baseline numbers for people who are
generating these sorts of engineering
documents to consider on the back end
how much maintenance is required so this
this brought me back to some stuff Chris
Tikko and I did in 2017 when when Chris
was back with us as a graduate student
the next slide Frank shows uh some of
the estimations we came up with with
Cornell athletic fields so we looked at
a bunch of the different athletic
facilities he's at Cornell and came up
by month with all the activities and the
frequency you need to conduct those with
we have scouting fertilizer irrigation
rolling in here and we came up with some
some estimates of hourly requirements to
maintain those fields so so really my
rant today Frank is is when we build
these things you said it best the other
day when we were talking we build these
things and then we burden ourselves with
the maintenance afterwards and it would
be really great if we play in that
maintenance when we're building them
yeah and and a lot of it is is just
forethought and and Ben I talked about
this work that Carl and Chris did uh at
Nerf uh the her foundation uh a year ago
uh I talked about you know managing
division one sports fields and it came
from this it was really good to see Carl
the validation from the American
physical plant Association and and I you
know you know one of the things is we
have to explain this to people who don't
know anything about it and I've got a
point about this but oh let me see yeah
so first I want to get to the weather
and then I'm gonna get to the setup for
Ben so get a few other guys will indulge
me for a minute we'll go through a quick
what's been going on in March and what
are we going to expect moving forward
well no surprise to most people it's
been when you look at the whole of you
know the first 15 days of March happy St
Patty's Day right is it St Patty's Day
today Ben Where's your green are you
Irish Ben
no Hey listen you had two Italians three
Italians yesterday you got two Italians
and a Jew so it's not working out well
for us for Saint Patrick's Day oh we're
doing good all right so so so
um just uh warm conditions so far in
March and generally what uh we heard
from art yesterday our climatologist is
that the the fall and winter the winter
saved us from the drought we were in
last fall it was really dry going into
the winter uh and the precipitation
we've received especially where you are
Ben you were pushing 200 percent in
normal uh we're in a little bit more of
a dry spot out here Carl hover in just a
little bit below normal and the New York
metro area is always fascinating to me
right it's really good right around the
city and Brooklyn and Queens and then
you get to where Beth Page is and it's
bone dry uh right in the middle there
and it's very funny how precipitation
can be continuously spotty like this now
the thing that's really interesting is
I'm really glad for the snow for the ski
places gosh those New England Ski places
finally had a decent year I think for
the most part they're certainly above
normal in March but as you can see the
rest of the Northeast uh significantly
at or below normal for snowfall and of
course that's essentially says that not
a lot of people had to worry about snow
mold this year and if you're worrying
about snow mold you're probably worried
about it from micro dokie and Patch more
the pink snowmold than the gray snow
mold that requires you know long periods
of snow cover well and art said this too
yesterday he goes we're getting a little
cold weather but then it's going to just
go and it really looks like April uh is
going to get warmed which really is
pertinent for our discussion today and
it's a 50 50 chance about what it's
going to be rainfall wise this is the
hardest thing to predict it does look
like the great lakes in general are
going to be wet but it's not clear
whether it's going to make it to the
east coast one of the other things we
talked about yesterday with our our
climatologist is yeah the air can get
warm but that soil's not going anywhere
anytime soon and this really drives
breaking grass out of dormancy and it's
really important to understand we're
pretty good sometimes at getting it
green but that doesn't mean it's growing
and it can put up with the traffic and
the wear people see green grass it's
like oh let's get out there green is
different than growing uh when it comes
to the spring now Ben here's here's the
setup for today uh I don't know how many
text messages you got during the Super
Bowl I've got 32.
uh oh I haven't talked to them literally
15 years are like Frank what WTF with
this field and of course you know I
boast so they think I'm involved in
everything right Ben probably your
family thinks you're involved you're
involved in everything right so I got 32
messages this is very interesting from
my perspective one is it really draws a
light to what we do even a negative
light like any press is good press right
to a certain extent Homer throwing them
under the bus was probably not the best
move for the NFL but I think in general
you're starting to see more professional
responses and more attention being paid
Carl and I got an email the other day
because this goes to trying to explain
what happened at the Super Bowl the
people who don't know anything Carl and
I got an email the other day from
somebody involved in our New York state
school facilities thing and he sends us
an email wants us to get involved in a
publication band much like we're going
to talk about in a minute your bmps
this is what he said in the middle of
the sen of the paragraph we needed to do
just take a minute think of it as trying
to explain to someone who just started
as a director of facilities how to
manage grass at a district and their
prior experience was a maintenance
supervisor for a plumbing contractor so
this is what we're tasked with just
about every day especially in the
Sportster business maybe golf it's a
little bit different but but I don't
know
now to address this over the years and
particularly because we've had pesticide
bands in place here in New York state
for a really long time we have a really
comprehensive website that people can go
to and get information in fact Ben your
publication links to it on many
occasions which we really appreciate it
is so great and one of the things we
address in here is working with coaches
and athletic directors now big kudos to
the New England sports turf Managers
Association uh and my old grad student
pal Vicki Wallace
um is that Chris and I don't know the
fella to the right Ben who's that fella
to the right
but that's our president-elect art
goodheim okay art and Chris I know he's
a familiar face correct and that's picky
Wallace the stick the turf extension
specialist uh in Connecticut and there's
Ben uh and probably a picture he he
enjoys seeing with with the things that
matter most but I know you probably had
to take a lot of time away from them to
put together this best management
practices now the Mid-Atlantic had done
one right this is your version and it's
one of I'm just gonna highlight a little
bit do some high level and then we'll
chat about it really good whenever you
do bmps you have to start with the
regulatory framework you have to
understand what especially in in
Municipal environments where you know
you guys are involved in in you know
working for the municipality that
enforces these things you guys are held
to a higher standard so paying attention
to this this book has a very
comprehensive list in fact I thought the
soil Health one was particularly the the
soil Health one was particularly
interesting this happens to be the
legislation stuff now
this we'll talk about how to get the
book but these other things that you've
done which I think are consistent much
like our website what should you need to
New England well one of the things you
need to Unique to New England is you got
these Patchwork pesticide bands you've
got these restrictions in certain places
you've got heightened awareness and
concern about these sorts of things so
this case study that you did with Rick
Peruzzi up there in Maine where these
things are happening is is incredibly
well done you know what we learned at
the bottom of these hey oh sorry at the
bottom of these case studies he what
what do they say every three to four
years you need a pre but you can go this
is the kind of language we need to talk
not I gotta have priests every year all
right how long can I live without them
this is absolutely brilliant big shout
out to Rick now of course this was one
particular one was uh near and dear to
my heart because the phrase mowing thing
citing the work that we did with Chris a
number of years ago taking out the weed
seeds right and this has been published
by Jim Brosnan and the folks at
Tennessee and then this one was really
interesting the robotic paint job thing
especially with how long this thing will
run you can't swap the battery when it's
exhausted it starts clogging and
wobbling painting erratic lines so you
know this is the kind of stuff that you
we're really grateful to guys like
Brendan who do it and then tell us about
it right they take the time not just to
do it but to tell us about it all right
Ben we'll uh I wanna before we get to
these questions let's go back to the
document here talk to us about this
document give me a a little bit more
than an elevator speech what's the
Genesis of it and what are your plans
for it yeah so so uh so Vicki and I
Vicky headed up the uh sfma document a
few years ago was right around when
covet started and you know she was uh
stma sfma at the time wanted a BMP
document we put together uh sports turf
managers practitioners Educators
extension uh and everything and built
the document on the national side uh and
and that was good and then always the
goal was to have some Regional bmps uh
and really Maryland as you said kind of
LED that that charge uh and the idea
being is the sfma document was kind of
that template but we could take that
template and bring it to a region
and then put our own spin on it if you
will put those Regional
information that that's important to us
like you said like the pesticide
regulations uh one of those things uh
you know we don't need to talk about
Bermuda grass here really overall though
maybe we need to and we did leave some
of it in a little bit
um and then really what we did is and
then like I said for our nasma document
we took again practitioners Educators
Sports surf Managers from New England
brought us all together brought the
national document in and said how can we
make it our own uh and and certainly
kudos to Vicky and and uh Alyssa in her
office they worked tirelessly tirelessly
on this project which which again was
funded by the New England Regional
Turfgrass foundation and that's key we
we National could not do this without
them
no way uh we spent a lot of time looking
at the document
and uh making as many things new
england-based as we could and then as
you said from the case study perspective
we kind of looked at
um other bmps golf sports turf other
places around and Maine did something
really interesting where they they added
these case studies in which we really
liked and as you kind of hit on it it's
really good practical information and
they're one page right it's one pick
where these are set up the one page
front and back and always the idea was
this is something that could be left for
agnesy purposes for legislators
um for someone like my boss who again it
was a facilities director who doesn't
know things about sports turf or grounds
but can understand this from a Layman's
perspective of what we're doing
um so the the case studies we didn't
include them in the document because
they're always we think they're always
going to change right we think we're
going to have these
be new every couple years I think is
that what we're thinking about as
Technologies like the robotic painter
come into into uh fashion
um just different different things we're
learning about
um so it's a it's a really fantastic
document I just I can't say enough to
kudos to Vicky and Alyssa and all the
other participants who really help with
this it was it's a great deal I haven't
been involved in the goth one uh here in
New York state
um I know the lift that it is and it
usually Falls to just a few people at
the very end to get it over the line and
uh in my case with golf it was Stacy
Kingsbury here in New York state and Ken
Benoit and the guys down there but you
have to have a key Core group of people
this is good for other people maybe from
other states or other areas that are
listening to this this is the kind of
thing you could rally an industry around
right Ben I mean this brought a lot of
people together and that in and of
itself is is really good now I will say
too you guys have done a really good job
in bringing sports turf managers
together in New England in a way we have
not effectively done uh here in New York
state so that is also something we have
not found a way to Rally our sports turf
managers uh as effectively as you guys
have done and then have that
relationship with the regional Turf
foundation so listen how are you gonna
distribute this thing you have a sort of
unique way you're thinking about it uh I
think it's it's I I if me if I was in
New York right now I joined the New
England Sports Turf manager's thing just
to get this thing period yeah right and
that's what we're looking at yeah yeah
so so it's it's our it's our document
it's an asthma documents proprietary
um and we want to offer it to our
membership as a member benefit and we
think that's really important
um so you know it's available on our
website it's a locked document like I
said you have to be a member to uh have
the document have the case studies uh we
did print uh a quite a few a number of
them but as you said there's a lot of
links so that so the the PDF document is
really the living document where we link
to a lot of different
other Pages uh other fact sheets and
things so it's really it's I think it's
much better than the the book itself but
everyone you know Everyone likes holding
on to a book still for certain for
certain things
um so we encourage people if they want
the document become a national member
when it's that simple and then you have
the opportunity to have that document
it's perfect congratulations well done
now thank you okay
this is just great I'm so glad we can
highlight it like this and you can go to
the NS you know you can Google the New
England sports turf managers and I'll
take you right there
uh you can can you sign up online
absolutely
perfect there you go okay so Ben that
how about your work now
um it was uh I mean we had if I'm not
mistaken I don't know if Carl swanger
Golf Club but I know it was in the 60s
and 70s for a few days in February
uh and we had two weeks of really warm
weather and I'm sure you did too and and
and you know this thing called Cabin
Fever is a known uh issue it is
something we've diagnosed back in the
old days you know before we had social
media people were still nuts before
social media came around left lest
anybody forget it's just we didn't know
about how nutty everybody was but people
had problems with Cabin Fever they got
locked up so the minute you can get out
Ben they want to use it now you came to
mind immediately as Carl and I were
talking about this
um because there's a lot of science
around this stuff here's what I can tell
you the grass isn't growing it's going
to wear out if the soil is fine textured
and wet it's going to turn to Mud
there's not a lot of research you have
to do on these particular facts what you
have to do this is where the science
ends and the management picks up your
use of sneakers on these kids right in
the early season uh is is that
Innovation so first off what do we do
with early spring split play what I call
fall spring you know they get that play
and now you got this crap they want to
get back on it is there anything you can
do in the fall let's look back for a
second that sets you up for
what you want in the spring
yeah sure absolutely as much work as we
can do in the fall to get these fields
prepped before spring is what we end up
doing and and like you said we had a
bunch of great weather in February we
were doing ball field work in February
we were getting uh new infield mix in we
were working uh foul line areas
um you know we were we were getting
pictures Mound and played areas ready to
go uh while the weather was good you
know strike while the iron's hot
um we cooled down very quickly here in
the fall so it was a few things we
wanted to do late in the fall that we
just weren't able to do like what um
like what just more balls feel prepped
than anything else
more the skin this is yeah more the skin
yeah yeah I mean we obviously want to
have 100 Turf cover going into the into
the uh the winter season
um so you know we're constantly
overseeding going mouth areas we've been
doing that no matter spring summer fall
we're doing that anyways
um we actually did try a little bit of
covers this this winter on some gold
mouth areas I did pull back the covers
back in late February I did have a
picture of that on Twitter
um everything's still down uh I'm
actually going to go up today and take a
peek under and see what it looks like
now that we lost all the snow here
um but yeah having 100 Turf cover is
certainly important I will say this we
are lucky here in West and we have
enough Fields so we do a field rotation
schedule
yeah we take a field offline every year
every sorry every season and we rotate
around and I get it people cannot if
you're landlocked I get it you can't do
that
um but we're lucky we're able to do that
so we have one of our main lacrosse
Fields offline uh this Springtime and
still debating on what we're going to do
for some extra maintenance while we have
that time to recover
and and I think the thing is it you know
you're right not everybody has that
luxury but that's a piece of information
that is good to pass on to people as an
aspiration it's look you want better
Fields you need a few more period
especially if you want to use them at
times when you're not assured to get
good recovery right so so do you then
you know obviously you tell them they
got to wear sneakers right that's is
that's the move early on yeah so we have
we have youth startup pretty much next
week or so maybe depending on the way
that The Field's dry
um you know first week in April and
we'll reach out to our basically it's
our youth soccer Youth Lacrosse for the
first couple weeks or so well before
they have games and say you know we'd
love you to use sneakers do they all
listen no of course not they don't all
listen but if I can get 50 of them to do
it that would be great
um but you know when I got guys to work
on it today we have two synthetic right
and that's that shoulder season of the
muck and the nastiness that we have uh
we have high school sports starting
Monday they're going to be on synthetic
for a week you know and I've already had
conversations with our athletic director
I said listen first week all synthetic
he said yep no problem you let us know
what you need what you need us to do
yeah
um perfect and and we'll get there you
know they're going to want to jump on a
ball field you know they want to they
want to throw the baseball around the
diamond no questions asked right
um and we'll get there we'll get there
you know long range forecast looks
pretty good in the next like seven to
ten days so I think we'll have some skin
Fields uh you know potentially ready to
go
yeah and we're gonna do that's great and
I gotta tell you that's great I'm glad
that you brought attention to the
infield mix because every year we have
my favorite infield guy Evan machete
from Penn State to hit the work he's
done is pioneering and I don't think
anybody's even paying attention to it
except the MLB guys who have been
perplexed by this stuff for a really
long time and there's no standards and
specs for it the clay is really
difficult Carl I want to give you a
chance to ask Ben maybe some operational
questions or anything else before we
wrap up today
Yeah you mentioned there a little bit
Ben but the communication with with an
athletic director or coach uh that's
integral right in in outlining the
expectations for the spring and saying
hey you know we've got this long range
forecast so we might be able to get you
out but but I'll keep you updated could
you talk a little bit about the
importance of engaging with those people
and and some of the best ways best
practices to approach them when you're
saying something like hey we got to hold
you off the the ball fields for a little
bit what's what's the best way to go
about that communication
yeah I mean it you know it's it starts
at the beginning long before this of
having a good relationship with
Administration athletic directors uh
even our our youth uh coordinators uh
Our Youth Sports presidents having that
I had a I had a coffee at the coffee
shop with the youth baseball president
last week and it's you know it's just
having those relationships that make
going forward having tougher questions
and tougher answer sessions uh together
so having those good relationships I
have a great relationship with our
athletic director here he's a very easy
going guy which is great
um you know and and and I get it some
people just they're go they want to go
go hey uh College baseball's been going
for a month already right and it's you
got to deal with who you got to deal
with
um and we're lucky here that it's just
we have those good relationships and we
don't we don't start super early
um and again like you said having those
having those conversations about whether
having those conversations about
um what what do we really need and I I
have those with some of the our new
sports what do we really need for uh the
fields live exactly we really need them
all online do we need some of them lined
do we need goals other places do we can
we use cones right so let's let's spread
them where let's spread the damage and
and you know we're going to work with
you as much as we can yeah and being
Nimble right Carl being Nimble is really
important because stuff's always
happening with all those fields yeah
Frank and you've had some experience
dealing with some of the the Cornell uh
coaches here as well but asking the
right questions and asking them to give
certain types of input rather than
others right you've talked a lot about
tell me what you want to see in the ball
as opposed to tell me if I should mow it
higher or lower or rolling right it's
almost about two kinds of coaches
there's two kinds of coaches those who
can tell you what they want and those
who who feel like they need to tell you
what to do
just tell me what you want I can figure
out how to do it I'm a professional at
this right we're professions at this and
I think that's really fundamentally what
I want to end with Ben is there that
relationship that with per with someone
also requires some professionalism it
doesn't mean you don't get dirty it
doesn't mean you don't work you know
wear messy clothes sometimes because
you're out doing something that's got to
get done it means that you know what
you're talking about you're consistent
your you understand their side of the
situation and are sympathetic to it
instead of I you know you know the old I
was re-watching Ted lasso this is very
funny I'm because I want to watch the
third season the very first episode when
he shows up and gets near the grass the
guy runs of course don't step on the
grass don't step on the grass right in
the beginning of it and I think we need
the other thing which is my job is to
get you on these fields not to keep you
off of them my goal is to have you use
them as much as you want and never
restrict you is the goal right Ben it's
just not always easy
oh exactly that's exactly it
and take it a little cue from
Cube from our shirt
clean off those pants and having a good
conversation with someone
um you know sports store managers don't
have the best uh track record on some of
that and yeah image absolutely yeah it's
image and and we needed we need to do a
better thing a better job doing that uh
and like I said that starts way before
the season starts uh with having those
having those uh good relationships right
Ben thanks so much for taking the time
to join us Carl another thing fast 30
minutes too fast it goes back by too
fast we're breaking the time time space
continuum like uh like Back to the
Future thanks a ton Ben for joining us
uh we'll see you guys next week Thursday
Friday a golf show and then we'll get
some some landscape folks there on
Friday take care everybody thanks Carl
thanks Ben see you guys
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu